good evening  so this morning our negotiating  team returned from london after a week  of  intensive negotiations they informed me  about the state of play  and the remaining divergences i had this  evening  a phone call with prime minister boris  johnson  on the ongoing negotiations between the  european union and the united kingdom  we welcome the fact that progress has  been achieved in many areas  nevertheless significant differences  remain  on the three critical issues level  playing field  governance and fisheries both  sides underline that no agreement is  feasible  if these issues are not solved  and whilst recognizing the seriousness  of these differences we agreed that a  further effort  should be undertaken by our negotiating  teams  to assess whether they can be these  issues can be resolved  we're therefore instructing our chief  negotiators  to reconvene tomorrow in brussels and i  will speak again  to prime minister boris johnson on  monday evening thank you